hey everyone I'm Ian Hecox and Anthony
Padilla and we created Smosh today we're
gonna show you the last things on our
phone I broke my phone right before I
came here it's a very cracked and the
only way that I could keep glass shards
from from penetrating my fingers is to
have it in a ziplock bag this is called
the I wish I had a phone case phone case
so in the hotel
the toilets had this really good
lighting and this mirror and I was like
I look this looks like pretty cool so I
took a I took a selfie of myself take a
selfie of yourself whoa what I that's
unheard of looks almost like Bohemian
Rhapsody yeah it kind of does yeah I was
like wow this looks really this is like
the most dramatic photo I've ever taken
and I'm about three inches away from a
toilet that's covered in other people's
urine mine is of this mirror over here
actually in the corner over here I
called it lens of truth because if you
look at it it gives you such a close
look at your face that you just you look
disgusting and you can see every single
blemish and dead piece of skin on your
face and you automatically look 80 years
old the last well the last video it took
it wasn't a video that I took as a video
I saved and it was of my random cameo
parents on one of our second Channel
videos and I show off my butt and then I
give him a little flex and then I give
it a little a good rule of grabbing
these are some very self-indulgent
videos and photos you go over here you
have any naked pics on there - Oh dad I
saved surely for snapchat mine is a
woman talking about a shelf are you - I
was gonna buy a shelf and I needed to I
needed to know about the show do you
need a lady to talk about a show yeah
I'm not gonna buy a shelf from someone
that doesn't talk about the Shelf that's
a little weird I want that personal
connection with the show that's just
kinda weak this is high budget yeah you
only want to buy the highest quality
nobody can buy this show unless we got a
nice dolly shot of it that's all you
sure that you buy it though
the last thing I Instagram is gonna look
really funny what my phone the screens
all cracked and messed up but the last
photo I took was a selfie the cameras
all messed up the the actual selfie
itself is messed up as well its selfie
probably can't really see anything mine
is a picture of me just waking up and
I'm like I got a lot of sleep I look
great
did the eggplant emoji accompany that
picture I was shirtless and there were
many eggplants to be had the last thing
I googled was the stuff called umeboshi
boshi umeboshi do you know what that is
pickled plums yeah I had no idea what
that was I saw it on a drink menu and it
came in one of my drinks I was like what
the hell is this
it looks like rotten dates to me I don't
download ABS ever you got like seven
pages of apps that's not but I don't but
I don't put anything in here you don't
put anything in a folder what is wrong
with I have one I have one folder that
has a notch of apps in it titled
which is apps that I never use
also a bone folder fine
it's just be called dead and that was
the last thing on our phones if you get
anything like shards of glass oh yeah
I'm bleeding for sure